well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages
in the next half hour or so then we'll
see what's making the headlines with the
comedian and virologist riolina
and the parliamentary sketch writer at
the telegraph madeleine grant
who is not there yet but i'm sure you'll
hold the thought for us in just a moment
first of all then let's just check out
the front pages shall we starting with
the daily telegraph leads with
prime minister boris johnson stressing
that the astrozenic vaccine
is safe amid concerns over a very low
number of
rare blood clots among inoculated people
that story is also splashed on the
metro's front page which writes that the
european union
has ruled the vaccine is safe and
effective
exploited is the headline on the front
page of the delhi mirror
referring to the 30 000 nhs staff
who did overtime while fighting the
coronavirus front line
front page of the financial times is a
report that david cameron
lobbied the government to increase
finance company green cell capitals
access to state-backed clovid 19 loan
schemes
months before it collapsed
and there's the guardian pm backs jab as
row grows
over boasts about the roll out
so let's get the thoughts of ria as we
try and establish madeleine
we can't quite hear her is the problem
we can see her but we can't hear her
it's modern life i guess isn't it uh ria
um but this is this is right down your
street as a as a virologist the daily
telegraph
the job is safe uh the the thing that
isn't safe is catching covid
and this is the the risk benefit
analysis that was done both in the uk
and in the european union as we watch um
those european nations
start to re-roll out the the astrazeneca
process what have you made of all of
this
well it's it's been a very interesting
few days hasn't it i think that we're
all
quite rightly concerned that there may
or may not be side effects that the
trials that they did last year didn't
come up with and that's a normal and
natural concern
but the ema decided uh to reinvestigate
this the mhra have also
looked into these 30 cases we're talking
about 30
cases of blood clots uh in
in individuals after having had the
astrazeneca vaccine
after that of course as you know a
number of countries in europe
italy germany france and
sorry italy i've written italy twice
italy italy germany france
the netherlands a number of them stopped
the vaccine roll out as the ema
decided to look into this today they had
a press conference and they have
confirmed that they have completed their
investigation and found that the vaccine
is safe and effective now a lot of this
is a numbers game we've been thrown a
lot of numbers over the past couple of
days
i think the the one that we've heard is
that there were 30 cases that was 25 in
europe and five here in the uk
of these unusual clotting events in
individuals they have resulted
in a couple of deaths which is
incredibly unfortunate
and so they stopped to look into these
cases and overall they found
that there is no causal link between the
vaccine
and these clotting events and and that's
really what i think many of us
want to and need to hear because of
course we've seen as well which is
unfortunate even here in the uk we've
seen a slight increase it's been
reported
by doctors and vaccine vaccination
centers across the uk
that we've seen a slight increase in
cancellations as people get worried
they've been worried about what this
means and today we've heard definitively
from both
the ema and the mhra that this vaccine
is safe and effective and again going
back to the numbers
what they said is that we've seen 30
cases of clotting events out of about 20
million people which actually translates
to a much
lower incidence of clotting than you
would naturally expect to see
in the population if we weren't going
through a massive vaccination rollout
if anything some doctors have said that
because it is such a low incidence of
clotting that
the vaccine might even and again let me
stress that we haven't done the studies
but they suggest that it could mean that
the vaccine prevents
against certain clotting events because
the incidence of clotting is lower
in the vaccinated population uh we did
see that it was
uh in the trials uh that they that they
did before
we started using the astrozenica
vaccines we saw some clotting events in
those
in those phases in the phase iii trials
but we saw clotting in both
those that were given the vaccine and
the placebos which is why
overall they've told us
this is okay this is safe and effective
and we're not seeing numbers that
are are cause for alarm oh real we've
got madeleine back so let's introduce uh
madeleine grant hello
sorry about that i think it was you know
it is it is modern life we all know this
don't we from uh from having
conversations at home
um via these means um we were talking
there about the
the many of the newspapers leading on
the fact that the jab the astrazeneca
job is safe and effective
the metro going exactly on those words
um but the message today from the mhra
doubling down on caution i guess was
please report side effects you know four
days headache
bruising around the sight of your arm
you know let us know and this is really
important is it to
to re-establish i suppose real
confidence in this job
well i think that's it exactly it's also
i think to create a sense of
to contextualize the risk in the way
that rio was just doing so well
um putting into the context of other
risks and the pm and
the chief medical officer went to great
lengths to try and say that you know
they kept reiterating the point that uh
the jab is safe but what isn't safe is
is catching the virus but unfortunately
i mean i think thankfully
they said that though there has perhaps
been some slight hesitancy now in taking
up the vaccine
as a result of the deeply irresponsible
comments being made by some eu leaders
on the continent um that actually um it
hasn't had that big an impact on take-up
here in britain but i suspect the damage
that's been done
across europe where the polling shows
that people citizens across
continental europe are now feeling very
hesitant about the oxford
uh astrazeneca jab um there's a it will
take a great deal
more of this um across europe to try to
counteract this level
of misinformation and i think that's
partly why the pm was
was uh very delightedly sharing the news
that he will be getting his jab
tomorrow along with many other
50-somethings yes and it could
be that the the pfizer jabs that are
available will now be going to second
doses
because many of the early cohorts had
fires didn't they because that was the
only one that was available at the time
so it could be that that is for
practical reasons apart from him trying
to send that pr message out there
um but ria this is the point isn't it
what do europeans do now it's good to
see their governments very quickly
restarting their programmes some from
tomorrow some next week
and many people pointing out that this
jab is at cost that was insisted by
oxford university when they tied up with
astrazeneca and it is also very
important for
other parts of the world this for many
countries is the only job they've signed
up to
yes uh that is a a wonderful thing that
we should be shouting about
is that the fact that astrazeneca is is
producing this at cost there is no
profit margin
in this endeavor because everybody is
interested
in making sure that as many people as
possible can get vaccinated and you're
quite right this is the only vaccine
that many countries
will be will be using and so it's
important not just for
europe and the uk uh for everyone that
it is safe and effective
is the terms that we're using safe and
effective and and what we're having now
is exactly as madeleine pointed out is
and yourself
is that the way to go forward from this
event the way to
to feel yourself that you are doing
everything you can to make sure that you
get through this is is to take note of
your side effects
and we had this before in the uk don't
know if you remember that right at the
beginning of december maybe a week after
we started using the vaccines that some
of the side effects
were allergic reactions and we adapted
to that very quickly
and we now know to look out for that if
you have severe allergies you are told
please let your doctor know
when you go in for your vaccine and
we'll just make that same adjustment now
the adjustment now when people go in for
the vaccine where any of them whether
it's the fisa the moderna or the
astrazeneca vaccine is please take note
of your side effects if you have a
headache for more than four days which
is a common side effect
that we a lot of people are seeing from
getting the vaccine but if that headache
is lasting
three four days please do go see your
doctor if you're seeing some unusual
bruising
please go and see your doctor and this
advice isn't just for those being
vaccinated that's actually advice
for anybody who might be worried about
having a clotting event go and see your
doctor if you're having some unusual
bruising
because as we've already said and as the
numbers have shown it's not people
getting vaccinated having clotting
events these happen in the population
naturally
and everybody should be aware of these
things so it's just a wonderful way of
raising awareness generally about health
well i had my vaccine yesterday and and
despite feeling slightly tired yesterday
which i think was
the excitement of it all to be fair i
feel absolutely fine
i think they put water in me i'm so
worried about it now actually but there
we are
but uh let's move on shall we top of the
metro if we see that again
uh picture of sturgeon and salmond with
the headline sturgeon did
mislead parliament that is also in the
daily telegraph as well the news tonight
sturgeon misled the salmon inquiry say
msps
um madeleine right bring us bring us up
today it's very complicated story this
isn't it but
does this matter this this early verdict
on it
it it does yes and it is it is it's very
long and very complex and hard to follow
even people whose job it is to do so so
i completely get there
yes thank you um this is the news that
the hollywood harassment committee has
concluded
that um nicolas sturgeon's evidence
around the
non-intervention in the in in the in the
investigation
into alex salmond is inaccurate and a
potential breach
of the ministerial code and now i think
what will happen
is that the argument will now shift to
whether she
knowingly misled parliament or not and
that could determine um you know her
fate and if she is able to
um cling on but the telegraph reported
um and i'm sure it's been picked up in
some of the other papers as well
that there was a quite a tight verdict
on the committee four of the four smp
msps who sit on it voted to back mrs
uh sturgeon's version of events and uh
the four
tory lib dem labour and um uh
tori libdem and labour and members
believed um alex salmond
and in the event the deadlock was broken
by a single uh
former green mp who now sits as an
independent um but already since the the
news has broken
nicolas sturgeon does seem to be kind of
buckling down
she spoke to reporters outside her home
this evening and saying that the
the opposition members on the committee
had kind of made up their minds about
her before she had given a single word
of evidence
so it doesn't look as if this is the
words of a
of a lady who plans to go quietly
yeah she certainly accused the committee
of being bipartisan did she not but if
you look at foreign wires the way they
report this story it's quite interesting
they say fundamentally this is about
whether or not scotland has a path to
independence
which makes it very significant of
course we've got local elections coming
up in may haven't we
um whether that is the case or not you
know people should take note i guess
shouldn't they
just briefly rear about this
well the scottish people certainly have
a decision to make in the next month
i mean this report is is being delivered
right before parliament shuts
for the elections and so will actually
be considered by the new parliament
whether this particular report is going
is what everything's going to turn on
uh is is to be seen and it's for the new
scottish parliament to decide
once they're selected uh we still also
have to wait of course as you re
you know for the report from the irish
lawyer james hamilton who's going to do
a completely independent report
on to what as to whether nicola sturgeon
has breached the ministerial code and i
think
that report is going to carry a lot of
weight because he is completely
independent
of scottish par internal politics
bipartisan or partisan
is this my post-vaccine brain which one
is it madeleine
well i think it's all it really comes
down to fundamental issue of
of the kind of values that are governing
scotland i mean it's
i think it is connected to independence
in the sense that what's come out in
in well it's been coming up for some
time but it's really come to a head
in the last month or so is is that a
picture of a
really rotten looking government you
know as a
lying we know for a fact that at least
one of their last two leaders will have
been
lying on a kind of grand scale um and
even things like you know the fact that
nicolas sturgeon decided to
in the midst of the pandemic in early
january she was busy setting up a task
force for scottish independence rather
than looking at
tackling the pandemic and all of these
things which is actually something that
salmond
alluded to in his in fact i think he
explicitly said when he was giving
evidence
to the hollywood inquiry that you know
an independent scotland led by the snp
wouldn't currently be able to function
it you know it would be like a failed
state or something
along those lines it was really you know
quite serious words from
one of the the great the great fighters
for scottish independence
well done yes it is such a complicated
story isn't it but
well done to both of you we'll see if
more in just a moment plenty more still
to come
we will take another first look at the
papers which includes this story
in the financial times about how former
prime minister david cameron
lobbied more on that in just a moment
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now we alina and
madeleine grant
there you are welcome back to you um ria
let's go to the front page of the delhi
telegraph shall we this is the ongoing
issue
about how nhs staff should be rewarded
for the extraordinary
effort they did and they have the news
that people got
unpaid overtime in the crisis which in
itself is perhaps not so surprising
it's it's not news that the nhs staff uh
have been giving above and beyond
what any you know in the past year in
this pandemic
and i think we're all on the same page i
mean we were talking about partisan or
bipartisan everyone has agreed
that they deserve to be rewarded um and
this is coming back to this one percent
pay rise that the government has said
is affordable uh they said oh well we
we're suggesting one percent that's all
we can afford
and it seems like a slap in the face
when they're spending 2.3 million
on a on a press briefing room 9.3 on a
on a situation room and yet we can only
afford
one percent for the nhs and this comes
off the back of just
finding out that wales has decided to
give everyone a one-off bonus um
in in their health system of what
equates to 500 pounds
per employee uh following off the back
of scotland doing it
and so it's a real kick in the teeth now
of course this offer still has to go to
the nhs pay review body
they still have to decide whether or not
that
that is affordable as rishi sunat keeps
claiming it to be um so we still have to
wait and see whether that one percent is
is accepted by them or whether they they
come back with another number
did you have a quick word on that or
should we move on to the ft madeleine
yeah just to say i mean that this is
going to be i think this this story is
showing no signs of of disappearing and
actually alongside the huge sympathy in
the general public for
for a more substantial pay increase um
there's
there's
growing numbers on the tory benches who
who feel this way too and have expressed
that opinion so i think this is
definitely
going to be a difficult few months ahead
for the government as they
weigh up the politics of this as well as
the the economics
so madam let's go to the ft then uh
question is what do you do after you've
been prime minister
uh become advisers to various companies
which takes us to this story just
explain
uh what this one's about yes um
so this is a hell of a scoop from the
financial times it's the news that
david cameron uh lobbied personally for
greensville capitals access to
emergency government loan schemes um and
this happened months before the company
um collapsed which left the taxpayer
potentially on the hook for for any
losses
um and i have to say that you know i i
think we're going to have to get very
used to these kinds of stories when you
consider the
the sheer amount of uh government money
that's been spread out in all directions
i think this is just
the very tip of the the iceberg of
cronyism and
dodgy dealing that we can expect but in
a way i quite
i actually quite like this story in a
sense because it shows that
he doesn't he didn't get anywhere he
didn't he didn't succeed in his aims it
shows that
a former prime minister couldn't get the
government uh to take a different risk
profile in
relation to the scheme that he was
lobbying for you know people always
going to lobby but
in some ways i quite like the fact that
someone as senior as david cameron
actually
couldn't get the treasury to change
their approach okay we've got the times
in i think
we hadn't seen it before let's just have
a quick look at that shall we it does a
picture when it talks about the health
teams confirming that the oxford jab is
safe to use
but it does picture the cambridges there
by a mural
with a crown which says
healing heard so somebody some
photographer has managed to snap that
one quite cleverly
perhaps we can do that newspaper when
you come back at half past eleven
realina madeleine grant lovely to see
you both thank you